it was like a toss-up between the Comedy
Store and the Laugh Factory yeah I first
moved out here and then I was like I
know there's a difference
you're gonna chocolate sundaes at the
Laugh Factory I haven't fire that's one
of the most fire shows let me ask you
this Gary Owen is a white guy Brooke
does black who does black come uh-huh
right uh-huh so like when you go to a
Gary Owen show he could do chocolate
sundaes he could do all that [ __ ] yes
you're a black guy who doesn't
necessarily do quote-unquote black
comedy yeah I just talked about you just
talk about you and your experience right
but like we have you done like a black
comedy night yeah and do they [ __ ] with
you yeah the first time I did it man I
bombed so hard I bombed so hard I can
only imagine like it's just it's just
different it's like it is Gary Owens not
gonna go and like pull up and and and do
a show with Jim Gaffigan you know nor
small Gary Owen has the blackest
audience then like some white and he's
[ __ ] hilarious and he's [ __ ]
hilarious
but yeah you're right right yeah yeah
some of these like like he probably has
out of like most of them yes yes I'm
saying he has a his audience is black
you're not gonna see like a white person
in there or any other like it's black
I've been to a couple Gary Owen show
okay okay but no uh yeah the first time
I did like an all-black room yeah I
bombed hardest [ __ ] I was doing a
weekend and the club runner back home in
Arizona for the clubs I was doing this
to KC courier he was like you know he
was like building me up and he goes I
seen what you can do in this room what
can you do in this room and I went up
there now let's do this but I [ __ ]
tanked they did like I didn't get I got
I got three laughs at the start the
middle and the end other than that any
but it was the longest 12 minutes of my
life and I was waiting for the light and
then so then um but then that the
headliner that I was open for who wasn't
Rodney Perry okay shout out to Ronnie
Perry
he was like a man because I'm glad you
stayed you he goes that's good but
you're not clearing something up
immediately up top
he was like you gotta you gotta address
that you can't just like start telling
jokes he goes cuz thinking about black
people you know like perform for black
people he goes they got questions about
you as soon as you walk on stage he goes
and then he was like you completely
missed that you gotta say those things
off the red he's like you gotta clear it
up and he goes and then you can say
whatever you want after that because
they already know you he goes but they
don't know you right now and they got
questions they're looking at you
who's this [ __ ] yeah they're
like so different about him yeah they
know it they think he goes [ __ ] in he
goes he goes as soon as you grab the
microphone they know soon as you grab
the microphone you don't even have to
talk you they just know he goes you
gotta say it he goes so do all that like
up top and then I mean I went home and I
changed up like my whole set and then
bro when I tell you I did it I [ __ ]
didn't back out oh man he it was it was
like one of like the like greatest
moments my comedy career because it was
like [ __ ] yeah like guys I saw him in
and then they had this show at the store
okay what was it called it's on Thursday
nights damn it they gonna punch me in
the face for not knowing this one but it
that but it's all black room and
sometimes I would get my development
spots on that room and I already knew
like boom boom boom and like they they
the lady that runs it Michelle she
[ __ ] loves mean I always gave me like
more time stuff like that because
usually comics bomb that room you know
what I mean like there's a lot of it's
like you know I mean do black people but
black people are the best people the
best audience to ever perform for I can
imagine because here's the thing ain't
going write a blog about your joke try
to cancel you Anglo Charlie kids you
brought if you ain't funny they just
gonna say it on site not on Twitter
that'll do
they're gonna tell you right there yeah
think about it yeah the night people be
honest put the coolest moments I know
Jesus FK s gameplay was in the ground
running I had him dying I was like
that's fire yeah